it really varies it really varies it's
not uncommon for me to shoot the same
environment time and again until I get
it right because you never sure if the
moment that you have is going to yield a
better result than then if you wait so
ultimately film is cheap and now that
we're in the digital world and digital
era it's even cheaper so it doesn't hurt
to capture something just so that you
have it and and in that process also get
to understand more the subject that
you're in but this of course has you
know to do with the type of environment
that you're shooting if you're shooting
wildlife which is not my specialty but
I've done some of it you're going to
catch as catch can I mean if if if the
wildlife presents itself in the moment
that it presents itself you can't
exactly guide it or you know there are
some masters of it incidentally which I
certainly do not qualify myself as one
of them but who are incredible at
orchestrating certain types of
environments to capture wildlife again
that isn't at all my specialty but my
relationship to nature photography has
really to do with with an instinctive
and and spiritual approach to it how am
I connected to that landscape and how do
I respond emotionally to what it's
showing
well for landscape photography one tends
to to want to have the most amount of
information on film and because you're
not you generally are not behold into a
time frame that is rigid and dictated by
the by the celebrity or by the job you
have more time to set up and so I tend
to prefer shooting larger formats and so
primarily I'll shoot four by five or or
medium format or large format panoramic
which would be six x 17 or in medium
format 6 x 7 and that's what I tend to
to shoot landscape with and typically
exclusively with those mediums however
having travelled to the Arctic and
Antarctica I was met with the
limitations of utilizing this type of
format in environments that are
antagonists or how style to to the use
of large format and with that I mean
that environments that are particularly
cold and sometimes particularly wet and
sometimes physically straining those
conditions dictate a certain approach
and listen you have Frank Hurley who
would Shackleton carried around him an
eight-by-ten camera and came back with
extraordinary results and an incredible
hero for his commitment to I mean him
and Shackleton incidentally and the
whole the whole team for understanding
the value of reporting what they were
capturing but it's not easy I mean I was
in the Arctic and I was gun ho but
utilizing you know large format and and
was wholly unprepared primarily out of
inexperience but my equipment some of my
Quitman froze my hands were very cold
the conditions were particularly
challenging and as a result I just came
to realize that that extreme
environments just do not lend themselves
well to to that type of
Matt and so when I traveled to
Antarctica I understood that the digital
medium was was particularly well-suited
to those challenging environments so in
Antartica I shot large format and medium
format but primarily my my mode of of
capture was 35 millimeter digital which
incidentally with the new cameras is
quite extraordinary and yields amazing
results so I did ninety percent of the
work in Antarctica with with 35
millimeter digital canon specifically